Jud we're live on the air Jim just went
to the gym just went to the bathroom
I apologize you're coming in here
it really feels unprofessional but Jim
Jim's been having a problem drinking
cold Brews you know I don't I don't know
that's what he likes he likes to drink
his cobras it's Mike for Troy yeah he
likes to drink his cold brew coffee and
I guess it gives him the shits because
this is now the second time in two weeks
where he's just right after a break too
this is not the you know the freshest
space I've ever walked it is just an e w
radio and it was a fresher space it was
I tried to tell Jim that his scent isn't
welcoming to gas whatsoever I mean it
might be welcoming to certain people but
not you not me I don't feel welcome
otherwise might be like this is heaven I
like that that you can see you can't
speak for everybody I Who am I to speak
for taste right you can speak for
yourself only everybody has their own
thing I appreciate that what are you
gonna do yeah who is there any backlash
from from anybody in your life about
coming in here after Seth can't fold
everything because of Bannen well you
know it's a it's a fascinating issue
this idea of you know who should be
allowed to speak read and what we make
of everybody's opinions and here's the
problem the president has the worst
opinion of all he you know he's the
person that we wish was not on the air
and and I you know it's interesting you
know if Trump gets through four years
god forbid 8:00 at the end of it we
might go well that's America and it's
freedom of speech and it was good we all
shared ideas but if he gets us in some
war and kills a million people will
probably go yeah we probably shouldn't
have had all those people promoting this
but who knows I mean it's very hard to
develop opinions about it because there
are so many awful people that if if if
everyone who's awful is gone
it'll just be you know you know Sam
alone in a room just babbling to himself
right they won't let Jim come back from
the [ __ ] yeah I mean I don't really
have a strong opinion and whatever you
guys the opinion
and I guess your opinion is everyone
should speak because right and I also I
feel like it'd be I think Jim feels the
same way it'd be more of an issue if
Sirius was like we're just all right
wing people and this is what we do Bob
because Sirius is probably the only
place on radio where they have really
strong progressive talk shows as well
like that hasn't really worked much on
terrestrial radio its kind of gone away
it's complicated because it is someone
who's Pro pedophile so if you if you if
you adjusted it a little bit right
there's this a guy hey this this guy is
gonna have his own radio show he wants a
pedophile yeah go [ __ ] kid although in
the Senate and and he also got the same
guy thinks women shouldn't be allowed to
do almost anything homosexual should be
in jail and the same guy thinks Muslims
should not be allowed in any legislators
right but he's not totally closed off
against everybody pedophiles are okay
it's it's accused pedophiles Rome or now
now is said why didn't do anything
actually well he certainly said Muslims
should not be allowed to be in Congress
or the Senate right and that goes
against the Constitution Roy Moore said
that you mean yes yeah that's his
position right that is an open position
homosexual should be in jail and so when
you when you pay him you're basically
saying we got this great guy he thinks
but you think he's against freedom and
religion right he's into we love him
anyway and that's what bad into saying
that we he supported that guy before the
pedophile stuff and then stayed with him
but I also think that like when you when
you say like okay well I'm not gonna get
involved with serious because of that
guy you almost turned him into this
super villain which has been his appeal
you know what's complicated about it we
do all believe in freedom of speech but
the you know companies decide who they
want to pay to speak right and so you
know if I was in charge of a company
that wouldn't be my move if they said
like yeah the guy who doesn't believe in
freedom of religion I wouldn't be
wouldn't be writing checks to him I
understand why it's what's happening in
this country so in a way you have to
honestly reflect what the conversation
is precisely but in a way are you
promoting hate speech and probably you
are you're promoting someone who thinks
that people who
love with each other who are the same
sex should be in jail are we going to
see Benin yeah did you know I don't know
I just sense that you mentioned Seth and
that's what the direction of yeah so I I
think you know all these things are
coming out of so quickly it's hard for
us to decide what we want to do how we
want to process it
I appreciate that Seth did that because
you know the things you see and like we
anything about like Cosby and Harvey
Weinstein and all that is nobody has the
balls to make any sacrifice of their
career or their potential to make money
in order to stand up for anything so if
a guy knows Harvey Weinstein hurts
people but he's gonna make a lot of
money in the next movie he's probably
not running to the heads of agencies and
studios and saying let's shut this guy
down oh I'm gonna lose millions but we
gotta shut this guy down he's hurting
people no one does that so the idea that
Seth is saying you know what this is
important to me I have the disaster
artists in theaters I'm not coming in I
I respect that I think that you know
that's a very strong position and you
know for me
I know all this stuff is happening so
fast then I might I'm dizzy from the
amount of scandal and the amount of
people with ideas that I abhor but do
you think it becomes dangerous though
when you start like I don't like
Stephens use on gay marriage Allah at
all but when we start saying that wants
you in jail I don't care really clear if
he if he really do every about joke he
would have issues with it but yeah
that's fine but I don't like his opinion
I think his opinion on that stuff stinks
but do we get into a dangerous area when
we start saying that I don't want that
person to have a voice because his
opinion sting that's really really about
who you pay for their voice everybody
should have a voice but a company
decides who to pay to speak and so this
isn't a freedom of speech issue in terms
of should they be silenced should we not
cover him
he's on a salary and so if there's a guy
who is really like violently against
foreigners trans people homosexuals
Muslims and we're saying I'm gonna pay
that guy to say more that it's [ __ ]
weird now I get he's been here for years
and that's part of you know the
complication of this which is there may
be 10% of the country that are
agrees with him and does it make sense
for ideas to be shared I don't know I
don't have a strong opinion about it yet
I'm just processing it but I do know
it's really [ __ ] up and I'm really
disappointed in the country that they're
not disgusted the fact is there a lot of
people's country or like go-go-go and
this stuff is horrified think though
that I understand people who don't like
the guy I definitely get it cuz I don't
like a lot of his using it but then you
get stuff like well how about a lot of
the actors who have stood by Roman
Polanski knowing what he did no I know
one is a bit of power the word that's a
lot of them yeah and who gives a [ __ ] if
Chinatown is good he put his well let me
not get graphic
nobody did do that and and it would snow
and then he did that yeah and a lot of
actors like no one is saying hey if you
worked for Roman Polanski I'll never
work with you again no one is saying
that but a galaxy ban and they're saying
your opinion stinks and we kind of
preferred people don't hear it well
there's others levels to it you know
some people have opinions about who am I
to judge I wasn't there and you know you
could debate whether you agree with that
or not but that's different than being
the person who says Muslims should not
be allowed to hold elective office or
being the person who says homosexual
should be in jail
so like the the person who is a level
passed it it's not exactly the same but
yeah if I got a call to do punch up on
the next Roman Polanski movie I would
say no do you think there's tons of
people I haven't worked with because I
think they're destructive people I'm not
against them
you know it's America if people want to
pay to see a Roman Polanski movie that's
legal I'm not gonna do it do you think
them saying who's to say I wasn't there
and I know a lot of people probably say
that do you think that's their way of
kind of giving themselves an excuse when
they really know what happened I think
people make a conscious choice to put
themselves in a fog so they can enjoy
things made by people or to work with
people who commit heinous acts so people
are just like they like kind of make a
choice to not remember so like something
you know I think that all got worked out
let's listen to thriller right make a
point tonight
go know Michael Jackson's insurance
company gave a kid twenty two million
dollars so someone had to make a choice
to write that check because something
happened you don't write a check for 22
million dollars you might write a
million dollar check to make someone go
away a lot of money two million have you
ever tried to get insurance money like
when there's like a fire or hurricane
you know hardly fight you grab two did
not pay so with they go yeah we've got
to pay that 22 million right as we all
decide like yeah but oh my god was that
an insurance company though how did he
have like molester insurance how do we
all get this insurance I guess you can
cover anything size of London or
something like some people decide like
you know they come up with ways to be
cool with it and I I don't care if you
like if someone wants to watch all that
stuff that's not my big issue like you
shouldn't watch it I don't care but if
you know someone's hurting people and
someone says like you want to hang out
with a guy and make something with them
it is weird to not care right you know I
mean he has multiple accusations it's
not just that one more of cámaras yeah
and and when you know I have a child I
know what a thirteen-year-old looks like
so when you have a child and you've
lived through what 13 looks like and
then you imagine a guy giving a kid a
quaalude and anally raping her in a tub
you think it's demented and it's and
it's it's funny how an industry could
try to ignore it because they like the
movies it's it's great yeah they
literally they hold him up and they say
that he should be able to come back and
they almost paint him as a victim well
they feel bad because his wife was
murdered in the Holocaust and but that's
not really an excuse everybody who
commits a crime usually has been hurt by
somebody else right it doesn't mean they
shouldn't you know pay the price for it
really is amazing that like you hear
that like people will like defenders
will say what do you know what happened
to his wife is pregnant take it and they
feel bad like it he's had a hard time he
had he had to stay in Switzerland
really rough now yes yeah I live in
France if you're drunk drive and you say
are your wife was murdered but you drunk
drove I can I can forgive drunk driving
for that bro
well if you find a guy in a bar but you
know there's really not any excuse for
giving a you know thirteen-year-old a
quaalude it is interesting what you just
said a couple minutes ago though before
Jim walked in that like you're at this
place and I think that you're right
where people don't know what the
historical implications are going to be
of this thing like this a lot of the
people that are mad about like what
Trump is saying and and it lines up with
what Steve ban and asset and stuff like
that are upset because of the potential
damage it could do but if that damage
doesn't get done well damage is getting
done which is trans people are getting
murdered because the environment has
changed there's more acts of hate in the
world and in America because like we've
like allowed these voices to bubble up
and get more active like things are
happening but you know when Reagan was
president we all thought we were gonna
get him into war with Russia right and
then that didn't happen and russia
crumbled and some people think reagan
was part of that some people think
that's not why they crumbled but it
didn't happen so suddenly reagan's like
it was kind of a good president he stood
down everybody then you have george bush
who you know now everyone loves him he's
a painter and he's all cute but like how
many half a million people died in that
war which he which they faked evidence
to create a war and so clearly he's way
worse than trump right he's way worse
whatever his decisions led to people do
not exist and right now we don't know if
in the trump era he's gonna create like
the george bush level or damage or he's
gonna get voted out of office and a lot
of people lost health care and a lot of
rich people got richer and it's not
gonna be the devastation of what the
iraq war of leash we don't know yet we
can't forget jimmy carter [ __ ] up by
giving the shah sanction really pissed
off radical islam yeah absolutely i mean
i think that a lot of repercussions you
don't know but what i don't like is when
people are just explicit you know Bannon
is X you know explicitly supporting the
worst people and also you know there's a
train robbery happening in this country
I mean the fact that people got excited
about Trump because Trump was like we
were gonna attack the banks and we're
gonna drain the swamp and do all this
and then the all he does is give money
to wealthy people and that all of his
supporters aren't furious
the estate tax saves Trump whatever two
to four billion dollars if he actually
has money well that's just stealing
money that's all it is it's he's not
about to create jobs with that money
you know if I'm about to get a tax break
let me tell the world I'm not creating
more jobs and so this idea that we
shouldn't pay for infrastructure as
opposed to just giving rich people money
and hope they create jobs is ridiculous
and it is rich people paying for
politicians who who give them a lot of
money if you make a billion dollars a
year and there's a ten percent the tax
break that you didn't have before
you just made a hundred million dollars
so if you gave a million to politicians
to try to get that done you got nice job
of that so when you start making like a
ton of money
did you never go through your phase when
you were like oh I just figured out how
much these taxes are they can't take
these taxes I'm a rich guy now
I love Maxa I have my own nuclear army I
have the roads paid there's hospitals
everywhere I there's never a second
where I going I'm getting ripped off I
can't believe there's infrastructure to
the world but I felt that way from day
one don't mind paying taxes for that
stuff
now you're right that's I don't mind my
money going up to hospitals helping
people but the problem is that when they
take money and they dump it in places I
don't want them to dump it and they
waste the money like I'm just giving
other countries money right for doing
certain things in the UN you know we
talk about gay people well you know look
in America do gay people are not
necessarily treated great but you know
in other countries some are who on the
travel ban they're being thrown off
rubes yeah and they're being thrown off
roofs altmer it's not a secret so uh you
know America treats you fairly well
compared to other places but yeah the
taxes I kind of agree with and I kind of
don't like I don't like to see my money
wasted I don't mind it going the
government is a mess and I agree there's
a lot of waste but what's happening now
isn't a thoughtful look at how we spend
money it's basically every agency being
dismantled it's almost like Trump's
trying to say look we don't need any of
this I'm not even gonna fill positions
to show you that nothing works but what
you don't have is like people the State
Department who are talking to countries
so that we can communicate in that
wind up killing each other right yeah I
mean so I don't mind personally I don't
like this scam of it I wish it was
simpler and made sense and and I hear
that the tax bill makes no sense that it
acted out that they are looking at it
that it's cruise rich people in ways
they didn't expect it's not actually
functioning properly I'm all for a flat
tax just yeah it's simple
that was Steve Forbes I think suggested
a seventeen percent flat tax which was
fair you know if you made a hundred
dollars you paid seventeen if you made
ten million you paid 1.7 million
whatever it would be
I don't think that's unfair at all but
for some reason I think is the IRS knows
that would kind of have much less of a
function if people could just do that
math you know whatever you made x points
to seventeen right that's what you [ __ ]
yeah and what do you need money for
anyway like I have I have more than
enough money what do i buy i download
some music I buy books mm-hmm I might
take a vacation I can afford my kids
college beyond that if you're like the
Koch brothers or something all you're
doing is buying ranches and taking gold
helicopters to islands I mean there's
nothing to spend money on so if you're
just like a you know a pig of
consumption you might be like I need
more billion well what do you do do you
are you a guy who spends a bunch of
money on weird [ __ ] or no you end up
just stocking it away I don't spend
money in anything I'm like you know what
I've got Spotify but I'm also gonna get
title I'm gonna get beats and but but
really that's about it or Sonics in HD
don't mind it though hey watch you lose
that much I'm still gonna get it it's
right off your entertainment it's right
off cable all your TV all entertainment
is a right and sometimes I'll get the
other appetizer I'm gonna get both Wow
when I was very young I was eating with
Roseanne and Tom Roseanne Arnold Tom
Arnold and Tom ordered vaguely it was
like uh-uh we'll take some of those
shrimp cocktails and chicken fingers he
would never even tell the people we
amount right I thought oh that's having
money he appears to be indulgent I was
surprised I was watching the Netflix
special which I believe comes
tomorrow is that right so night at
midnight tonight right the Ranieri say
this I'm at Gotham tonight with Colin
Quinn oh my god what a show I'm saying
goodbye to my act because when your act
airs absolutely should do it anymore so
tonight's the last time I'll do my act
at Gotham in New York and then tomorrow
at the 92y doing like a QA but I
couldn't get anyone to interview me so
I'm interviewing myself are you really
and I feel like a monologue or a
one-person show I'm just gonna show some
video at Loudon Wainwright it's gonna
come maybe I'm trying to convince some
other people to come and just visit for
fun so if you go to jet Apatow com you
could see the last two performances of
the year awesome and I like to did there
was multimedia by the way on the show a
lot of photos on this special yes you
know to illustrate stories so like I
tell the story about throwing out the
first pitch a Mets game and there's just
so many photos of it going wrong jazz
hands throwing the ball you suck did you
suck throwing it did not reach the plate
it literally rolled and didn't even
reach the catcher and the crowd just
booed so hard it's like you have this
sight
it's like horribly like it looks like
you're going into some kind of like
anaphylactic shock as you're throwing
the ball like an instance it's this
terrible freeze-frame and close-up of
his face it's just it's too much
pressure so much pressure to get your
mechanics correct especially because
like I also assumed that you must
because you're like you must be this big
Mets fan well then you revealed on the
special that you hadn't watched the Mets
since 84 Kevin Mitchell did you practice
first before use for the pitch I think
the day but before I did a little bit
and then right before you go in the
stadium and you do it and you're you're
doing it well about half the time and so
you realize it's 5050 that you're gonna
throw it way to the right oh yeah so
best-case scenario you're at 50/50 yeah
the best-case scenario and I'd really
did get super scared at the last second
but when they announced my name like
rise you're saying throwing out the
first pitch at a Patel I in that
millisecond I thought owned
No I'm about to find out from 50,000
people how much they like me because if
it's like jay-z they would explode right
and to the oath or the first page Oh
Judd Apatow and I'm like oh no what
happened without to find out how much
I've impacted the culture and then it
was like this smattering of applause
that was so lame so as I walked to the
bound I literally got depressed like no
one cares about me and I end it threw me
into a panic and then I threw the being
booed had been better like like Ty Cobb
said he liked to be viewed on the road
at least there was an effect it might
have been better it's a sign of thing
better than indifference differ a
smattering is awful was like I said
throwing out the first pitch is
Manhattan borough president Abe
Rosenthal it was that level of we don't
care and I don't want to give away bits
but if you haven't seen it yet Jim the
the shot-by-shot of the paul mccartney
meeting it's just the funniest goddamn
thing in it it also reminds you that
like no matter how famous you think
other people are they're still not quite
famous enough I guess Paul McCartney you
know I basically party kept coming to
the Improv watching shows and he's so
nice and I've used his music in movies
and I thought I'm gonna ask him to lunch
and I said I do but I knew if I if I
gave him my vote by phone number by
email that he wouldn't use it so I said
hey how do I reach you and I held out a
pen and a paper his paper and he lifted
his arms up in the air like like to get
away from the pen in the pad and my
friend Mike Khurana who works in the
improv he took a picture like a burst of
photos when you see it do they see the
photo of McCartney and he's sitting
there with a pen and paper and
McCartney's got his hands and what did
he think you wanted an autograph no I
said what's your what's your email and
it was the gesture of I will not be
giving you my but yeah he's so nice and
I've seen him since and he'll like give
me a hug and say hello which blows my
mind you're not getting me well he
wouldn't give you that's really funny
it's and it looks
so good wait hard is it giving it away
if you say what he said when that
happened or no you know it was very
vague it was yeah I was also trying to
get him to come see me I was doing a
show with the Randy Newman he's like oh
I know where it is I know where it is
how I'm looking and then they told me
that he was actually about to come to
the show and then he realized he had
another event but I'm gonna pull it off
I think the special airing is somehow
gonna lead it and and if he sees the
pictures everybody sued you a beatles
photo I just loved it like you're you as
much as like you're credited for kind of
creating the entire new wave of comedy
and film as we know it you're still just
a fan it's getting turned down by your
eyes who's turned you down because you
love taking the photos who's turned you
down oh I've been turned down by Mick
Jagger Oh Nicolas Cage you used to have
a grantor Ross you used to have before
denude De Niro stories yeah the old De
Niro story was Austin hero is what my
first celebrity turned on Frank Vincent
was my first De Niro turn me down
kissing Aerosmith yeah and I was trying
to walk backstage my friend was
backstage was gonna bring me the seed
you know gene and I see Frank Vincent I
go Frank I'm such a big fan we take a
picture he goes now not now and I'm like
I got the camera ready and he goes I
said not now he shut me up to Jerry
Lewis at a boxing match and he's like
hey Jerry as did you big van and the
other reason I got in common you know
and then Jerry Lewis goes go back to
your seat
my favorite one that I ever saw we've
told this story a bunch on the air
before but I went to a tech Comic Con
with Norton and like when you go to
comic-con and there's just kind of
celebrities about one of the funnest
things is to just watch Jim try to be
like is that somebody is everybody so we
were at this event for something that
William Shatner was promoting called
my outer space com didn't quite take off
like a space no well we're sitting there
in the gym it's like yeah let's hang out
here and a little VAR Burton walk
nice you know and Jim go psycho I'm
gonna try to get LeVar Burton and I was
sitting there on camera duty like okay
and Jim goes over to levar burton and he
goes hey man I'm a big fan would you
mind just taking a shot with me and
levar burton looks at jim and he goes
yes but first allow me to complete this
mission and he any wanted to do
something at the event but he called it
a mission like I was a Star Trek fan and
then he goes to the stage to like try to
get Shatner's attention and Shatner like
looks down at him and doesn't
acknowledge him and just keeps it was so
great to watch him get [ __ ] who
shatters into him what he just did to me
was so satisfying right then we're
sitting there watching him write with
Jim is just like we're gonna get him oh
we're gonna get him we're getting now
it's become this spiteful thing now it
is a mission we follow him as he walks
away from the stage and he goes into the
green room area and we follow him there
and a couple of the girls start talking
to him he's like oh we should take a
picture whatever Jim sees him take a
photo with the girls anything
we got him come on over he takes the
photo with the girls he says goodbye to
him and Jim just gets next to him he
goes okay and one more he was so [ __ ]
miserable when he saw that it was me he
knew he got got he wanted no part of me
sorts of those like just getting turned
down but you know uh just great weird
photos the one the one that I really
liked was that a Steve Martin was
talking to Mick Jagger at this Oscar
party and me and Paul Rudd I didn't know
either of them and so what we did is we
walked to either side of them while they
were talking and we had a friend walk
over and we like acted like we were all
talking yeah and the picture is amazing
[Laughter]
chatting about the award show yeah Mick
turned me down I was in a hotel in
Beverly Hills and I walk into the gym
and I'm in this like yoga area just
doing some like whatever I was doing and
I walked back into the main gym area of
the hotel there's two people in the
entire area Mick Jagger and his trainer
yeah that's it Wow and I'm like holy
[ __ ] you so I had my phone and I go to
walk back here I'm like Mick and he goes
sorry might no photos it was just us I
was like
I was like all right so I didn't bother
him I asked myself you know I said I was
just saying that Springsteen was walking
down the street saying uh not gonna
happen today that they saw a Dennis
Miller tormented story this isn't like
in the 90s and he was walking down the
street with a William Shatner and people
would all say hello this is before
people took photos sure everyone would
say hello and he would just keep his
head down and everyone so I'll just put
his hand up doing the live long and
prosper maybe like that it's got to be
draining when you're that famous you
Mick Jagger's not famous he's that
family where everywhere you go everybody
wants to photo an autograph one more
thing like JFK jr. was flying the reason
he flew his plane yeah is because every
time I get on a plane people would talk
about how much does father man like you
just can't get a moment away from who
you are people don't quite understand
what a nightmare that is that everywhere
you go people throw the camera and
they're shooting video without telling
you a lot of times we're just scary
you've watched not only you but like
everybody around you all the freaks and
geeks are people who were kind of just a
bunch of weird kids at the time had all
become yeah that level of famous right
funny because the first guy who got
famous from our friend group was Rob
Schneider so Rob Schneider had the copy
guy remember make copies and he was the
first guy copy and that was a big thing
he was the first guy where like people
would walk up and we were like oh my god
that's so weird
I remember Jonah said the day after
super bad came out that it like
everything had changed
and like wow but certain people are very
recognizable like some people can kind
of slip in and out I remember Jim Perry
would always get recognized because he
was so tall and he people jollity I
never been in the Romanum he's gotta be
six two or so but he is you when he
walked in a room you knew he was there
and we were in a bookstore in a mall in
New Jersey I think we were doing like a
stand-up show and people started walking
up to him asking for his autograph this
is an early 90s and then suddenly you
realized this was in living color Jim
yeah okay the entire mall was headed
towards the book store
turning into a hard day's night Wow and
it was the first time where I thought
we're literally in danger right now like
there's an entire mall running at this
bookstore did he sign Jim did sign I
think you know Jim had appeared where he
was trying to figure out what to do like
sign or not sign and then he tried the
thing where like he said like you know
I'm not gonna sign but I'll talk to you
and he did a funny thing which is he
would not walk away bet he would say
like I'll talk to you for as long as you
want [ __ ] what what's that it would
actually wants human connection right
they all want the picture or the
autograph how do you feel about like
because you've now obviously your wife's
an actress but you put your daughters in
movies yes so do people if you're out
with the family people want a picture
with the whole Apatow crew you know
there's a level of Fame that's perfect
yeah which i think is what we have which
is let's say on a scale of one to ten
we're where to now we're 1 and 3/4 and I
remember Garry Shandling always said to
me I have the perfect level of Fame
because most people don't recognize me
but when someone does they're very
excited to see me and I feel like we
have that but they're not even that
exciting you're hired
now you're higher than two level famous
yeah yeah yeah you're higher much I
chose your wife much higher than that
but you know I mean when we go places
it's we're not hassled much and most of
the time I think we might be at a level
of Fame where people recognize us
but don't care enough to walk over yeah
like I would say you guys are a six
level Fame that's pretty good level of
Fame like where's McCartney's at ten
Jagger's at 10:00 yes yeah there are
people that you I always think it must
be weird to be Mick Jagger in every room
you walk in your entire life every
person in the room is so excited you
just walked in they're all looking for
you and there's very few people who are
not struck by the fact you're there yes
right very few people you also could
easily become more famous because
especially like with the Netflix thing
because you're putting your face yes
right like your movies are way more
famous than you are yes right well we'll
see I mean I've never done anything like
this you know I never about the response
I got my first review in the Orange
County Register tonight I tried to look
at it quickly because I didn't even know
it was review I thought it might have
been just a promotional interview or
something and you know I did these
promos and the premise of the promos was
that I was talking to other comedians
and they were all telling me don't make
the special so it's it's like you know
Chris Gethard and Birbiglia and they're
like yeah don't do it why why risk it
don't do it and Amy Amy Schumer is
really funny she's like don't do it and
I'm like I already spent the money Peter
she's like okay do it
yeah and so in this review they're like
should he have done it and then he's
like oh yeah that's pretty funny I guess
so yeah so I guess that's about to
happen up but you know I'll just like
say to someone just send me the good
ones but I hope people like it I mean
I'm proud of it I think it came out well
and it was